[Music]  i used to be loved  i used to be a kid detective we're all  really counting on you  i was so far ahead of the game  but one day i just woke up behind this  guy in my homeroom claims she's  practiced with the mets i need to find  out if he's lying  he's lying  so what can i help you with somebody  murdered my boyfriend  seriously pretty seriously he was  stabbed 17 times  is it possible he was involved in drugs  no  he would never do drugs gambling no he  would never gamble  demon worship no he would never worship  a demon  here comes the kid detective  [Music]  someone's following us this isn't safe  they're trying to see how my head works  somebody's testing me  [Music]